hey this is really funny just because it
once again sort of pierces the false
notion that all these right-wingers and
trumpets want is to have transparency
and conversation and dialogue and
exploring our differences in a
respectful way Donald Trump jr. was
booed off stage when it was announced
that he would not be taking questions
during a book tour event and there's
kind of almost like a recursive nature
to the way in which speech was curtailed
it's very interesting now the other
element to this is that the audience
that did the booing is a generally
speaking Pro Trump audience it was an
audience at an event organized by
turning-points USA this is the pro Trump
group that sped spreads pro Trump
propaganda on college campuses they have
a couple of people at charlie corks and
candice blends and or owens i forgot and
they're well known in the circuit they
love Trump Trump loves them it's a whole
scene right so Don Jr shows up at UCLA
for this book tour event to promote his
book I guess technically it does count
as a book even though the writing can
only be considered writing in the most
technical sense the audience is told
there will be no Q&A and they go crazy
chanting Q&A and stuff like that and
ultimately shutting down the event and
Don jr. having to walk off the stage now
one more thing before we look at the
video and listen to the audio you will
hear a woman's voice pop up that is John
juniors new girlfriend as many of you
may know Don Jr is now dating kimberly
guilfoyle who is a former Fox News host
she's been traveling with Don to his
events and being part of them even
though it's only actually a bigger
distraction if you saw the appearance of
Don junior on the view continually
getting into arguments with people while
adding nothing and then in would pop up
kimberly guilfoyle talking over people
in trying to haphazardly defend on
junior it all just doesn't make any
sense she's just traveling around he
he's traveling around with the former
Fox News host who runs interference for
him like it's all just extraordinarily
weird anyway she's on stage as well
let's check out the first video
sees me and that that is the problem and
the reason oftentimes it doesn't make
sense to do the Q&A is not because we're
not willing to talk about the questions
because we do
we've done smoking to go for some sort
of sound but you have people spreading
nonsense spreading hate to try to take
over that room your parents probably
being rude and disruptive and
discourteous
[Music]
so that they can hear you don't play by
the same rules let me tell you something
I bet you engage and go on online dating
because you're impressing no one here to
get a date in person
[Music]
many people view catfish
[Applause]
so they are not pleased clearly with the
lack of a QA how patronizing is it for
kimberly guilfoyle to tell the students
that their parents wouldn't like their
behavior right now it is so funny in so
many ways and on the one hand it's
pathetic that he's not going to do a Q&A
right the whole thing with these TP USA
events is people get to ask questions
and sometimes the questions are
adversarial but sometimes the questions
are brown-nosing but whatever you're
doing questions and they're not going to
do it
so that's pathetic on the other hand
it's pathetic that anyone thinks Don jr.
has anything interesting to say that
they would be all broken up that there
isn't going to be a Q&A I mean it's
little the blind leading the blind and
in the the districtís sense and then the
video continues and Don says listen
we're ok with Q&A in principle but not
when it's bad faith or when people
derail it or whatever and then you'll
see them if you're watching cut to
another shot where the entire thing just
wraps early to resounding boos and they
just walk offstage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so TP USA is doing damage control
because when you hear the protests these
are not left-wing protesters right
these are right-wing nationalists
America Firsters pro-trump errs who want
their cue a so TP USA is framing it as
these are extremists this is just a wing
of the right
it is not representative of a mainstream
Trump supporter whatever guys I mean
have fun fighting about which contingent
of your movement was behind this but the
big takeaway is that as soon as they're
not in an in an absolute safe space
there immediately terrified and
triggered there was no big political
message here behind this protest of
these supposed extremists in the
audience this was some people who were
mad that they weren't going to get a
chance to ask Don jr. questions there's
no big political or philosophical
message in the dumb protest but notice
how when Trump senior Donald Trump the
president shows up at a sporting event
and people boo he looks visibly shocked
and he's grimacing when Don junior shows
up and people boo they just shut down
the event after having his girlfriend
lecture the crowd about how their
parents would be really displeased with
the way that they're behaving themselves
their protest doesn't even make sense
but it's delightful to see their own
side shut down their speech when all
they do is say that it's the left that
shuts down speech Don jr. has made a
speaking career and a book actually a
lot of the book is about this going
around saying the left shuts down
dialogue the left doesn't want their
ideas challenged the left doesn't want
discussion the Duff Duff doesn't wanna
have to answer to criticisms of their
ideas their followers go around saying
the same thing and what happens is that
Don jr. says no questions and the crowd
shuts them down it's ironic in
since not that they have any ability to
see irony but what it really proves
actually is the bad faith net nature
with which all of these political memes
become perpetuated and they're actually
meaningless and we're gonna talk about
this on the Friday show there's a
question on the Friday show about sjw's
what happened to sjw's the question is
nothing ever happened to sjws there were
just they became a popular target of the
right and they to the extent that they
reflect a particular wing of the left
they have existed for a long time and
continue to exist but the right has
moved on to other things at this point
in the same way it's this irony of
they've been talking for so long about
the left wants to shut down debate and
they don't want dialogue and whatever
and of course anecdotally you can find
instances of everything when it is the
right that is so heavily triggered by
disagreements by having to defend their
ideas by someone who says I'm not going
to take questions and then shutting them
down completely these people are
pathetic and they will never see the
irony because they like the president
seem to lack some I don't know is some
switch in their brain that allows them
to see irony and double standards